agile companies have three traits they
learn fast they make fast decisions and
that whole process is is supported by
enabling technologists and for us or
from language and system model are the
enablers for things that you wouldn't
all we expect a small business like us
to be able to get engaged
I'm Robert Prince right managing partner
of Boca in Peru we're a safety and
systems engineering consulting company
we work in the oil and gas industry most
of what we do is focused on supporting
development engineering and operations
or oil and gas facilities probably the
last five years we focused on working
with high technology applied in the
deepwater drilling industry
so welcome technologists actually allow
us to develop a workflow which starts
with the thought process which we record
in notebooks where we build models we
test the models to make sure that they
behave like real things we can calibrate
them but once we've gone through that
modeling process in notebooks what we
then do is we write the code in metallic
language which is the language used by
system um we chose as the modeler
because it's integrated with willful
language and what that means is that so
we can develop models we can use those
models for example in Monte Carlo
simulations to generate States for the
system and then feed those states into
system model and that is a fairly unique
feature I think of the Wolfram language
and system model system
a key feature for us subsystem modeler
is the ability to interrogate the model
and in particular check the equations
and how they're organized within a
matrix form therefore solution because
any large complex system is relatively
difficult to ill and debug but with the
features that are included in system
honor that's now easier
we believe that system honor is probably
the best interface to allow you to build
Metallica code we've had some success
building virtualizations or for example
digital drilling rigs and the pace at
which we've actually done that in us
we've taken about a year and a half
while they're about to build the model
that I know others spent years
developing in large part that's down to
a combination of being able to prototype
the models in Mathematica
from that stage then go on panic shkoder
in the fanatical anguish within system
Allah and generally that workflow I
think is relatively streamlined and has
enabled us to do stuff in timeframes
that I think most people would be
surprised by
I think the beauty in the process is
that the controller is given back to the
engineer and that's very important if
you can keep the engineer engaged right
from the very beginning the
conceptualization right the way through
to exporting embeddable code it's faster
and there's less likely than making
mistakes I've often that clients say
that the way we've solved problems the
way we're presenting solution this has
been excellent and I think a large part
of that is the graphics and notebook
interface which allows you to present
results in a way that can be less a
delicate manipulate or presented
graphically in a way that would be
relatively difficult that we were trying
to use a spreadsheet or something else
but clearly the language enables certain
things and those things convey solutions
in a way that I think is very unique the
evolution of from Mathematica version 1
which I started using back in 1988
through to where we are currently has
been very carefully designed to ensure
the core language really was honored
right away through process and that's
because it was so well thought through
at the very beginning what that means
now is that using Wolfram language gives
you an opportunity to solve even bigger
and more complex problems but in
particular what's happening now is
they're integrating language with the
real world around us so for example the
idea that you can write code in
Mathematica exported to system online
them from their embedded on a
microcontroller is pretty remarkable
when you think about it it means that
that core language basically back in 88
is now heading towards what might be the
state of the art for embedded solutions